helping hands of henderson they were
founded back in march of 1995 this year
now marks the 25 years in which they
have served our community
when the pandemic hit like many of the
programs had so many challenges to face
a news now reporter sally jeremiah
shares their struggles and their
victories
our helping hands of henderson program
typically serves about 450
seniors in the city of henderson helping
hands is known for providing the elderly
with transportation to medical
appointments grocery shopping
social activities exercise and wellness
programs
when covid hit a lot of those senior
services closed up
during that time we had to shift pretty
quickly to figure out how can we serve
the needs that they were facing now
dignity health community manager
jennifer finlay says for most other
seniors
that meant isolation and food access
currently we're
serving anywhere from 150 to 200 seniors
a month
with home delivered groceries they've
teamed up with a number of community
agencies
despite the partners there were
limitations
we typically had a staff of 10 and a
volunteer crew of 50
that would provide transportation as
well as
delivering food and calling clients if
we needed to
so we weren't able to use our volunteers
anymore i think that every one of us
felt like overwhelmed at times
but none of us want to quit with just 10
staff
they are working to help seniors through
their deliberate human
kindness kits as well as providing
reassurance calls just to say hi
we're still here how are you doing what
do you need
cerise mcallister is a helping hands
clerk she says the best part of the
program
is the bonds they create with seniors
like her client bob
whom she takes to the heritage senior
aquatic center he just called this
morning and told us how much he
appreciates us
and what he wouldn't know what to do
without us their message to their
seniors
that we love them and we miss them a lot
sally garamillo 8 news now
thank you sally we are stronger together
join us tomorrow evening
at 8 30 p.m as we look back at how our
community has come together during the
cobit pandemic
again saturday night at 8 30 p.m we'll
be right back